bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale
aujourd'hui dans la halle trump
président des états unis il le disait
pendant sa campagne électorale le break
si tu sais quelque chose
mais si je suis élu ce sera brixi de
puissance 3 je crois qu'il a bien résumé
les choses
l'union européenne est un peu sonné que
et comment réagir on en débat avec nos
invités aujourd'hui si nicolas bay
bonjour vous êtes euros développer
français secrétaire général du front
national ici au parlement européen vous
siégez au groupe europe des nations et
des libertés face avoue richard corbett
bonjour à vous êtes eurodéputé
britannique
vous siégez au groupe des socialistes et
démocrates jusqu'en 2019 d'avoir au
moins au moins voilà mexique oblige
enfin jean quatremer vous êtes
correspondant du journal libération dans
la capitale européenne
auteur du blog coulisses de bruxelles
avant de débattre les images de ce
sommet extraordinaire à l'union
européenne réunissait pour la première
fois depuis l'élection de trump s'est
mise des affaires étrangères quelles
sont concrètement les inquiétudes et que
va répondre l'europe
on voit ça et on réagit juste après
sommet extraordinaire à bruxelles donald
trump résidents des états unis ici tous
ne sont pas inquiet certains ont même dû
pousser des cris de joie après la
victoire du candidat républicain
viktor orban très adroite premier
ministre hongrois tout comme le parti
conservateur au pouvoir en pologne trade
rome compatibles ou encore boris johnson
le britannique
mr bré exit donald trump comme je les ai
déjà dit est quelqu'un avec qui on peut
discuter je pense qu'il pourrait être
une bonne chose pour la grande bretagne
mais aussi une bonne chose pour l'europe
à mon avis c'est sur quoi nous devons
nous concentrer aujourd'hui à part ces
trois là les dirigeants européens ne
cachent pas une certaine inquiétude
jean marc ayrault soucieux de
dédramatiser la situation n'est pas venu
débattre mais il est très inquiet pour
la cour de paris sur l'environnement
l'allemagne craint pour les accords
commerciaux qui pourrait être gelée
un point fait l'unanimité si donald
trump a affirmé vouloir se désengager de
l'otan c'est peut-être le moment de
créer une véritable défense européenne
plus autonome
ce dont il est question au lycée
l'autonomie stratégique de l'europe
capable décider elles mêmes des enjeux
de sécurité que ce soit évidemment tant
cadre de l'alliance atlantique
voir dans le cas d'une coalition voir
dans le cas des nations unies voir
elle-même je pense en particulier à
l'afrique pas de drogue de la défense
incantatoire une europe de la défense
opératoire pardonnez moi j'insiste mais
une autonomie stratégique face à une
amérique qui se désintéresse qui va sans
doute se désintéresser de ne leur pose
la question à monsieur 30
posez la question à monsieur trump ou à
son ministre des affaires étrangères
c'est ce que fera federica mot guérini
le monde continue de tourner l'europe
continue les crises aussi mais également
les occasions que nous pouvons saisir
donc nous n'allons pas rester les bras
croisés
la chef de la diplomatie européenne se
rendra à washington avant le 20 janvier
date de la prise de fonction du nouveau
président américain pour faire part des
préoccupations européennes
on va faire part des préoccupations
européennes question toute simple cette
élection de donald trump d'un président
américain isolationniste tant sur le
plan commercial que sur le plan
militaire
est ce une bonne chose ou une menace
pour l'europe nicolas bay bah moi je
crois que c'est une bonne chose pour la
france c'est une bonne chose pour les
nations européennes que les etats-unis
défendent leurs intérêts bien sûr et je
crois que le peuple américain ne s'y est
pas trompé en choisissant donald trump
plutôt qu'il ait clinton mais que les
musiques la bonne nouvelle dans
l'élection de donald trump c'est qu'on
va plus avoir probablement au cours des
prochaines années des états unis
d'amérique qui en toutes circonstances
font la leçon à la terre entière
interviennent à tort et à travers ce
seulement le chaos et parfois même la
guerre je crois que le fait que donald
trump est exprimée pendant sa campagne
avec beaucoup de de nuances
contrairement à ce qu'elle peut être
caricaturées ici en europe
sa vision des relations internationales
respectant les autres grands ensembles
les autres grands pays soucieux aussi de
résoudre les conflits au moyen-orient
par un partenariat pas un dialogue avec
la russie qui avait été largement rompu
aussi bien par les états unis que par
l'europe au cours des dernières années
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle est ce
que je vois aussi d'ailleurs c'est que
ceux qui s'inquiètent delà de la
victoire de donald trump sont les mêmes
qui sait qu'il s'est inquiété du mexique
serre qui s'inquiète que les peuples ne
choisissent pas les candidats qui leur
auraient été prêts déterminés par la
caste déjà corbett stade rexie te fiches
ans 3 sélections
on sent que surprise oui mais quand
j'entends que je parle avec des nuances
ça c'est une grande surprise va se
passer celui qui sont internationales
il est par très nuancée dit oui parce
qu'un jour une chose l autre genre
quelque chose de très différent
je vois du front national c'est un
interrompre les gens pour qu'ils n'ont
pas fait la même chose d'ailleurs en
amérique et il est né pour ça mais
contre lui par le peuple américain qui a
fait le choix dans une certaine
direction
n'oubliez pas que madame clinton a eu
plus de voix que louise la cause du site
de leur système de collège électoral
qu'il a pu prendre la présidence donc je
ne sais pas si le peuple américain ont
conscience de cause
a choisi d'aller dans une direction tel
que vous le décrivez en faire le tour de
table jean quatremer une bonne chose
écoutez nos opportunités c'est la
première fois que l'union européenne se
trouve confronté un président américain
isolationniste depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale après la seconde guerre
mondiale les américains après avoir pas
mal hésité ont décidé de soutenir la
construction communautaire parce que
leur idée c'était que les peuples
européens fassent la paix après la
travailler ensemble et qui n'est pas
interrompre intervenir une troisième
fois sur le continent
là on se retrouve avec quelqu'un qui dit
simplement je vais faire mes propres
affaires dans mon coin et surtout je
suis opposé à la construction militaire
je vous rappelle que le 24 juin donald
trump est venu en grande bretagne en
écosse pour inaugurer un golf d'ailleurs
parce que c'est un businessman
milliardaire faut quand même pas
l'oublier c'est un homme du peuple qui a
hérité lui-même de ceux de ses parents
et il est venu et donc c'est quelque
chose de fantastique
et donc ça c'est une visite le brésil
est donc c'est quelque chose pour nous
c'est comme diraient nos amis
britanniques c'est un challenge c'est à
dire comment on va faire pour pour la
première fois de traiter avec l'allié
américain qui a non seulement se
préoccupe lui vraiment nous mais en plus
est plutôt opposé à ce que nous sommes
en train de faire sur le territoire
européen
et ça c'est un vrai danger est ce que
les européens vont être capables de
réagir tous ensemble notre reportage
vous l'avait bien montré sûr parmi les
27 ou 28 pays si on garde la grande
bretagne qui sont là pour deux ans mais
en disant ne pas renier 28 il y en a
qu'on sabrer le champagne aussi vous
dire qu'on sabrer le champagne
mais ce qu ont sabré le champagne c'est
ce qui bientôt vont arrêter de sabrer le
champagne parce que si jamais donald
trump fait payer les pays qui
accueillent des troupes américaines ou
décide de retirer ses troupes et bien
nos amis or ban les polonais et serra
vont se retrouver tout seul face aux
russes et là à mon avis on va entendre
une autre chanson alors les causes qui
ont conduit à l'élection de trapèze
existe en europe désindustrialisation
des classes moyennes oublié par par la
mondialisation rejet de l'immigration
nicolas bay oui je crois qu'il ya
plusieurs raisons je voudrais répondre
en un mot très rapidement à monsieur
corbett et ce quatremer on a
l'impression que chez les eurocrates
chez les partisans de l'union européenne
telle qu'elle s'est construite depuis
quelques décennies maintenant
il ya une espèce de panique à l'idée que
les etats-unis cesseraient leur tutelle
sur l'union européenne mais ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle ça voudrait dire qu'enfin
les nations européennes pour retrouver
la liberté on a vu d'ailleurs à quel
point cette tutelle des états unis qui
insuffla loin que oui je crois que oui
je crois que le mot n'est pas trop fort
parce que quand on voit les technocrates
européens qui en toute circonstance
essaie de satisfaire les intérêts
américains
par exemple contre la russie annonce est
contraire à tous nos intérêts au cours
des dernières années on a la
démonstration d'une finalement d'une
absence de volonté politique autonome
des européens et je crois que c'est le
cas le l'un des problèmes majeurs de la
construction en scène
ensuite je voudrais pas interrompu donc
savent-ils pas vu jérôme sur l'adhésion
soit la défense aubry intéressant ce que
vous dites parce que c'est vrai ce que
vous dites que les états européens se
vivent non pas sous la tutelle mais sous
le parapluie américain il en profite et
ça vous avez mille fois raison
mais c'est pas les eurocrates parce que
les eurocrates en l'occurrence ils n'ont
pas vraiment vous savez quand vous voyez
quand les néerlandais les italiens les
belges bientôt qui achètent des f-35 ou
la chine et américains au lieu d'acheter
du matériel européen
il ya un choix qui fait par les nations
dur c'est par exemple ce que ce sont des
parce que ce sont des peuples libres et
qui peut y avoir aussi les accords
bilatéraux
on n'est plus capable d'envisager
autrement que dans le cadre des traités
européens les relations entre les
nations
il peut y avoir tout simplement c'est ce
que theresa may en train de mettre en
place des accords de libre échange
bilatéraux ont tous les pays avec
lesquels la grande-bretagne a intérêt à
avoir des accords commerciaux sur
excusez moi je vous réponds rapidement
sur les raisons profondes de l'ex ans
donald trump moi j'envoie principalement
3 il ya bien sûr le rejet de la
candidate il ait clinton très contestée
représentante et caricature même
peut-être de la caste politico
médiatique mais il y en a d'autres il ya
le fait que donald trump se soit adressé
à l'amérique périphériques à l'amérique
des oubliés à cette amérique dont
l'identité et la sécurité ne sont plus
assurés ni défendu il ya aussi je crois
la volonté de protéger l'économie
américaine bien sûr avec une approche
libérale très libérale même parfois mais
en même temps une vraie volonté
protectionnistes de l'économie
américaine on appelle ça de
l'isolationnisme en matière de je crois
que ça consiste simplement pour les
états unis à défendre d'abord leur
intérêt parce que finalement ce sont les
américains qui ont été les grands
oubliés finalement des politiques menées
à travers le monde dans une démarche
très belliciste de
des administrations successives et je
crois qu'ils vivaient il veut y mettre
fin
richard corbett c'est vrai qu'il y à du
protectionnisme dont les propos de
monsieur tron protectionnisme qui risque
de coûter cher à l'europe d'ailleurs et
il rendrait à nous mais de 10 et qu'on
vous dit que l'huile paris suscitaient
des pauvres de ceux qui ont perdu dont
dans le système économique actuel
américaine a annulé par contre jack la
gym oublier ce sont les classes
populaires et on sait ce qu'il veut dire
si on regarde qui il n'y a pas une très
grande différence sont fonction du
revenu de la personne concernée sauf les
plus pauvres qui ont voté pour clint
donc et c'est pas une surprise
comme vous l'avait dit lui laissant un
millionnaire un capitaliste avec une
fortune à rytz et on va c'est pas
quelqu'un des classes populaires il est
arrivé qu'ils lui reprochaient d'avoir
réussi dans les affaires quand même
qu'est ce que vous dites sur le
protectionnisme est intéressant où on va
au on a le sentiment dans votre bouche
que vous reprochez aux états unis de
protéger leurs économies
mais pourquoi on le fait pas nous parce
que aujourd'hui les grandes sommes de
l'union européenne
la libre circulation avec des graines
des personnes évidemment sans
concurrence libre et non faussée toute
forme de protectionnisme et le fait par
exemple qu'il dénonce le taffetas qui au
jeu qui aurait évidemment une bonne
nouvelle
non parce que l'analyse du phénomène
c'est une évidence même si richard
corbett à fait raison de souligner que
ceux qui gagnent moins de 30000 dollars
par an ont voté à hauteur de 53% pour
hillary clinton et les 41% pour donald
trump
mais globalement je crois que l'analyse
est pas faux c'est à dire que ou ou ce
que demain trump a fait campagne il n'a
pas fait campagne à new york il a été
dans l'iowa
il a été dans l'ohio où là vous avez des
usines entières qui ont fermé il faut
voir un peu ce que c'est vous allez à
détroit et vous verrez un peu les effets
effectivement de la désindustrialisation
d'une partie de l'économie américaine
il s'est adressé à ces gens là ils
s'adressent à des classes moyennes c'est
exactement le phénomène qui fait que le
front national prospère en france c'est
à dire des gens qui n'ont pas qui ont
tout perdu mais qui ont peur de tout
perdre et qui se sentent menacés parce
que on peut dire ce qu'on veut
le libre échange et la préoccupation
après occupation n'est pas seulement du
côté de l'extrême droite et aussi du
côté de la gauche et d'une partie de la
gauche qui dit c'est vrai que le
libre-échange a profité aux jurés 1% les
plus riches parce que c'est là une idée
sur les pages internes en 20 19% qui ont
perdu tous les gains les ganda
modernisation ce sont des gars qui sont
pour plus tard et qui sont étendus lire
en clair ce qui permet à renvoyer les
pièces souvent pour une petite catégorie
voilà c'est ça m'est donc donc c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui dans la
mondialisation c'est vrai que celui qui
perd son emploi celui qui fabrique des
charentaises et demain effectivement pas
seulement à peut-être mais souvent c'est
notamment vous savez ce que fabriquer
des grille-pain les bas etc qui tout ça
est parti assez en chine la neige et
donc c'est des gens qui souffrent qui
ont perdu leur emploi et que peut-être
un jour il y aura de nouveaux emplois
créés c'est ce gars plat et on n'arrive
plus à combien il faut qu'on change
notre le logiciel globale de l'europe en
matière de libre échange et c'est pas un
hasard si les deux pays qui se sont
révoltés contre un libre échange au
total contre le capitalisme triomphant
contre la financiarisation de l'économie
ce sont les deux pays qui ont donné le
des leçons au monde entier alors la
grande bretagne et les etats unis c'est
extraordinaire ce qu'un des deux pays
qui ont pêché libéralisé qu'on arrive à
la fin d'un cycle en réalité le
mondialisme ultralibérale et l'idéologie
qui a dominé un peu les sociétés
occidentales après l'effondrement du
communisme et aujourd'hui c'est cette
idéologie là qu'ils se fracasser sur le
mur des réalités qui est racheté par les
peuples parce que ce que vous dites et
il me semble en partie inexacte les
peuples non seulement ils sont pas les
bénéficiaires aujourd'hui mais ce
mondialisme ultra libérale mais ils ne
le seront pas davantage demain on voit
très bien aujourd'hui que c'est là la
minorité la plus risquée de plus en plus
riches et la majorité pauvre qui est de
plus en plus pauvres partout sur la
planète et dans les proportions de plus
en plus importante dans parce que je
crois que ce qu'a fait le succès de
donald trump s'est finalement il a une
approche non pas idéologique mais
pragmatique en disant voilà la situation
des états unis voilà les intérêts du
peuple américain je vais m'attacher très
concrètement la démo est ce que vous
niez c'est que la mondialisation la
mondialisation c'est pas seulement des
trans et pas seulement des marchandises
par exemple qu'une mondialisation vous
ne voyez pas mais qui créent de l'emploi
qui la mondialisation du numérique
c'est un truc énorme et c'est là où vous
vous créez dans quoi je les startups le
numérique les gaffes à eelv aux
différences assez de l'emploi de demain
c'est ça qu'on aime et vous confondez
pas
la motorisation et le mondialisme la
mondialisation c'est une réalité bien
sûr les échanges sont de plus en plus
facile de plus en plus rapide à travers
et les déplacements y compris des êtres
humains à travers la planète etc
et c'est sans doute une bonne nouvelle
ça c'est le progrès mais le mondialisme
c'est l'idéologie qui consiste à faire
de cette mobilité un objectif en tant
que tel alors que en réalité cette
mobilité elle doit être un outil au
service du bien commun au service de
l'intérêt général
alors qu'est ce qu'il y en a tout le
monde d'accord avec ça hein
et vous m vous parlez avec beaucoup de
clichés mais en fait si on regarde ce
que nous faisons au niveau européen nous
avons un marché au niveau européen sur
le plus grand marché au monde mais
crucialement c'est un marché qui est
réglé avec des lois pour protéger les
consommateurs
pour protéger les travailleurs pour
protéger l'environnement va voir une
compétition fair lady exemple les néons
il ya deux milliardaires jour des
changes
on ne va pas changer ça avec l'élection
devrait un peu notre marché est
équilibré et le libre mais avec des
règles pour protéger les gens et on
libère l'extrême droite ne change son
règlement excusez moi excusez moi vous
raconter n'importe quoi mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les nations européennes
elles ont commercial que monde entier
bien avant que ce soit encadré par les
traités européens
si vous vous dites est faux puisque la
concurrence déloyale et les mêmes
organisé à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne avec des travailleurs
détachés votre groupe
votre groupe corbel comme d'ailleurs le
groupe ppe les deux gros groupes qui
dominent l'hémicycle du parlement
européen ont voté les travailleurs
détachés
c'est à dire la concurrence déloyale à
l'intérieur de l'union ce satellite
nouvelle trump en europe on sait on sait
le premier ministre du canada mais on
sait rire c'est ça qui vous inquiète
défendre à nouveau ses intérêts c'est à
dire avoir des accords commerciaux des
échanges avec les pays en crise en
arrière nicolas bay vous savez j peut
exister hors de l'union européenne de
revenir sur l'idée que ce soit
européenne messieurs 1 face à donald
trump a les européens redoute le saut
dans l'inconnu à vous en parliez les
dirigeants de l'union européenne craint
de la mise à mal des accords sur le
climat où le nucléaire iranien
de même que la position américaine sur
le conflit syrien et les traités
commerciaux
le point avec béatrice phazon donald
trump au pouvoir une victoire qui va
redessiner l'écart de la diplomatie
mondiale et le nouveau président
américain l'a aussitôt fait savoir le
soir de son élection
nous nous entendrons avec toutes les
nations qui voudront bien s'entendre
avec lui composer avec un nouveau
président américain imprévisible ce sera
tout le défi qui attend les dirigeants
européens
cette élection américaine ouvre une
période d'incertitude
nous devons nous attendre à une
politique étrangère américaine moins
prévisible et aussi à ce que les
etats-unis soient plus enclins à prendre
des décisions par eux-mêmes première
incertitude sur le rôle de gendarme du
monde
donald trump l'a répété pendant toute sa
campagne il veut rompre avec la
politique interventionniste
traditionnellement menée par les
américains
quitte à laisser le champ libre à la
russie de vladimir poutine
et pas seulement dans la guerre contre
la syrie et l'iran
oublions la sphère de la crimée les sons
totalement libre cours aux russes en
ukraine
est-ce que donald trump va aller jusque
là pour se concentrer sur son programme
américano américain est donc laissée
poutine et bien avoir le champ libre
dans sa zone d'influencé
incertitude également sur les accords ou
négociations en cours
que deviendront les discussions
commerciales du taffetas ou encore
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
même inquiétude sur l'avenir de la côte
21 et l'accord de paris signé en
décembre dernier est difficile
d'appliquer l'accord avec un futur
président américains climato sceptiques
même si ségolène royal se veut
résolument optimiste
il ne peut pas contrairement à ce qu'il
a dit dénoncer l'accord de paris
puisqu'il ne peut pas empêcher ce besoin
est d'ailleurs les entreprises
américaines sont les premières sont les
premiers à se dire qu'elles vont
bénéficier de l'accord de paris au sens
où il faut investir dans les filières
économiques du futur et dans la finance
verte
autre impact de l'élection de donald
trump sur le breakbeat le gouvernement
britannique chargé d'assurer la sortie
du royaume-uni s'est trouvé un allié de
poids avec celui qui s'est autoproclamé
mr bré xics pendant toute la campagne il
y a une relation particulière entre 30
et le royaume uni de theresa may et
entre 30 et le royaume uni qui a fait le
break site du côté de theresa may c'est
la seule dirigeante européenne qui n'a
pas eu de mots méchants de mots
désagréables à l'encontre du candidat
trump donc elle peut espérer avoir des
relations privilégiées des relations
particulières avec donald trump
on sait qu'elle était un peu empêtré
dans ce chemin difficile de deux sorties
de l'union européenne est le conte sur
donald trump pour assurer la sortie du
royaume-uni de l'europe
enfin l'élection de donald trump risque
de donner des ailes aux partis
populistes européens des élections
cruciales auront lieu dans les prochains
mois en autriche en italie aux pays bas
en france et en allemagne
et tous ces partis comptent bien
profiter de
effectif
voilà question toute sa part est ce que
vous pensez que le président-élu tron va
faire ce que le candidat trump a promis
jean quatremer
moi j'en suis absolument persuadé les
analyses et commence à lire d analyse
ici et là en expliquant que le candidat
que le président ne serait pas le
candidat qui va devenir raisonnable
qu'il n'appliquera pas sa politique
on a fait les mêmes erreurs d'analysé
par exemple avec netanyahu avait
contraint le mexique elle se fera pas à
la déjà existé par le de barbelés on
parle de barbelés de mur il y aura il y
aura un mur il existe déjà en grande
partie dont ils vont le prolonger ils
vont se renforcer mais il faut voir
netanyahu en et en israël
je suis partie des faucons israéliens on
avait dit il va faire la paix avec les
palestiniens
c'est tout le contraire qui l'a fait on
a vu avec erdogan on a expliqué que
c'était une sorte de chrétiens
démocrates donc un musulman démocrate on
voit le résultat ils en train
d'instaurer une dictature
on a vu avec poutine ont expliqué que
nom poutine ça serait pas staline c'est
en train de devenir staline sans
communisme mais en gros un dictateur et
donc faut pas croire une seconde que
trump ne mettra pas en oeuvre son
programme
l'élément nouveau c'est ce que j'appelle
la pl éléments du fou à dire que on ne
sait pas face à une crise à un moment
donné comment il va réagir c'est à dire
que la prévisibilité de l'administration
américaine devient devient extrêmement
difficile à prévoir
je crois les chars corbett après après
nicolas bay richard corbett s'inquiète
imprévisible on ne sait pas j'ai tard
que tu as raison qui va faire exactement
certaines choses qu'il a des cas qu'il a
dit des choses contradictoires et
souvent mais il ya de grands risques
mais surtout on sait pas avec lui le
théâtre qui va revirer et revenir et à
nouveau mais il ya de grandes risque
pour l'europe et c'est le moment pour
les paysans européens de tenir ensemble
dans ce meilleur même au niveau de la
défense
on parle d'un désengagement de le temps
des états unis c'est le moment de faire
une pas parlé d' armée européenne mais
de défense commune plus éventuellement
n'oubliez pas que président américain ne
peut pas tout faire lui-même il est
beaucoup moins puissant que
les ministres européens comme président
français hélas le congrès en deux
matches aux il apparaît une majorité
garantie au congrès il a pas il contrôle
pas son budget ya des limites nicolas
bay pour vous ça annonce d'autres
victoires break site élections de trump
président de la république annonce en
2010 à quand les peuples se
réapproprient leur destin en angleterre
aux etats unis
demain sans doute je l'espère en
autriche zadié du rdr et en france au
mois de mai c'est évidemment une bonne
chose et c'est la démocratie qui
s'expriment à nouveau moi je voudrais
bon quand même très rapidement sh4 mer
sur le le parallèle entre vladimir
poutine et erdogan et trump
tout ça n'est pas sérieux d'abord
erdogan l'islamiste a bénéficié d'une
très grande complaisance de l'union
européenne
il y avait à c 3 milliards de plus pour
des flux migratoires qu'il ne contrôle
pas ou peu et on a accepté le principe
d'ouverture de nouveaux chapitres de
négociation à l'entrée de la turquie
dans l'union européenne alors que en
revanche la russie défend ses intérêts
et c'est bien légitime et je pense
d'ailleurs que quand donald trump veut
s'inspirer de l'annuaire poutine il a
raison pour défendre les intérêts
américains
le seul problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne elle organise
l'impuissance collective des nations
européennes
et c'est ça le problème d'accord
l'europe différemment nous faire en
sorte que les peuples européens puissent
en a toujours
alors aujourd'hui en laissant les
intérêts des technocrates et nous
laisser richard corbett très rapidement
en europe
ensemble avec ses 500 millions
d'habitants l'europe peut faire face aux
états unis à la russie et pour défendre
les intérêts de pays européens si on
s'éclate
si on va tous dans notre direction celle
des états unis et la russie qui vont
dominer excusez moi mais c'est
l'opération c'est l'europe des nations
il est ivre si vous cliquiez sur la
mustang collective des meilleurs vous
ayez que vous ayez une vision nationale
c'est pas content et ça mais quand vous
expliquer que les peuples se
réapproprient leur destin comme si on
sent on passait de la dictature à la
démocratie des candidats oui quand on
gagne c'est gênant parce que ça veut
dire qu'ils ont contesté la démocratie
même si demain marine le pen perd ce ne
serait pas la vôtre donald trump quand
donald trump a dit qu'il contesterait
l'élection si jamais il n'était pas élu
ça en dit long
sur la façon dont les voiles de
l'information la haine il a quand jean
claude juncker nous explique qu'il n'ya
pas de démocratie or des traités
européens
là on est en pleine dérive dictatoriale
la réalité de l avait dit c'est que les
traités lorsqu'ils sont mauvais ils sont
faits pour être déchiré le nom et que
les traités quand ils sont mauvais on
peut en sortir c'est ce qu'a fait la
grande bretagne et personne n'a empêché
un grand temps de sortir la personne n'a
envoyé l'armée européenne mais moi je
retenir la grande et entendu ici même à
lui dire de cesser ici même dans
l'hémicycle du parlement européen
les eurocrates qu'ils soient du ppe ou
du groupe s&d où les libéraux qui nous
expliquer qu'il fallait tester le vote
des britanniques s'il fallait revoter
qu'il fallait ne pas tenir compte du 28
septembre au crac ou alors vous êtes un
eurocrates car vous êtes payés sur le
budget européen
je me suis vengé de payer bien vous
gagnez ontarien votre vie son budget
ropert s'cusez moi mais ce jour et
français qui contribuent au budget
européen je vous rappelle que la france
est quand vos buts et à déficit
merci merci à vous trois merci à vous
deux fois pour ce débat on le veut on
peut faire un combat debout au milieu là
bas merci à vous de croire en tout cas
d'avoir accepté d'avoir débattu ensemble
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis cela
pas de repères d'eau bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires bayer pas de combat de
boxe s'il vous plaît